[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire j'ai la joie de recevoir
aujourd'hui deux hommes pour qui j'ai de
l'amitié dont j'admire le travail
d'architecte rudy ricciotti qui publie
son manifeste légionnaires et
l'historien du cinéma jean baptiste
thoret qui sort en salles le film qu'il
a réalisé sur mais michael cimino
l'auteur de voyage au bout de l'enfer et
un livre sur michael mann l'auteur de
hits mais comment sont comme d'habitude
par des images de l'époque voici celle
que vous avez choisi jean baptiste
oui alors aussi d'agréables toujours
fatale non en fait j'avais envie d'une
image d'une de presse d'une devanture de
cinéma aujourd'hui si on avait 7 sort
l'image est intéressante mais si on
avait une image un peu plus actuelle on
aurait grosso modo de trois films
labellisés art et essai qui vont faire
sans doute malheureusement peu d'entrées
et puis on aurait une comédie où deux ou
trois françaises complètement in f je
cite pâti tout le monde les connaît et
puis on aurait des films marvel alors je
dis ça non pas pour me lamenter du
niveau du cinéma mainstream ça tout le
monde était d'accord etc mais ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que je vois beaucoup
aujourd'hui de gens ou d'exploitants qui
se sont levés contre le streaming les
plateformes type led flix en disant
c'est pas normal qu'on puisse
éventuellement projeter des films
netflix en salle que soit le film de
jane campion de martin scorsese etc etc
et comme si le cinéma était un essai de
temples sacrés qui avaient été
respectées pour ça or moi ça fait 20 ans
que je vois en salles des films dont je
concert qui n'ont rien à y faire donc
j'aurais aimé que beaucoup de ces gens
là se réveille à l'époque où il faut il
me projeter dans des salles de cinéma
ces fameux temples sacrés ou et bien des
films marvel ou des téléfilms français
ou des comédies complètement inepte et
les voir se lever parce que scorsese
pourrait éventuellement être projeté
dans une salle de cinéma ça m'amuse
beaucoup
donc là l'indignation elle est sélective
et parfois une sorte de retard à
l'allumage qui peut un peu nous énerver
et puis moi je pense que ce sont les
films qui légitime de cinéma et pas
l'inversé c'est pas parce qu'on met
quelques heures dans une salle de cinéma
qu'on a affaire à du cinéma et c'est pas
parce qu'on met un film sur une plate
forme qu'on a à faire un film de
plateformes je veux dire le irishman
pour prendre cet exemple de ce que de
scorsese est évidemment du cinéma est un
grand film donc à ce titre là il devrait
être en salle alors que bout d'inepties
un compte qu'on peut voir un convoi ya
dix-huit films à peu près par semaine
qui sortent il ya combien de films de
cinéma là dedans combien de films dont
l'écrin et la salle de cinéma il a très
peu en réalité eux devraient plutôt être
en streaming donc voilà j'ai toujours
tendance à penser que la salle de cinéma
tout objet qui rend dans les salles de
cinéma n'est pas forcément du cinéma ces
deux films qui vous dit si c'est du
cinéma ou pas vous les photos vous avez
choisi eudialyte shetty c'est moi oui à
l'instant parce que pourquoi pour le
mauvais goût selon elle ce que
représente taddeï dans sa capacité de
résistance à la terreur pornographique
du politiquement correct c'est à dire
faire survivre encore une certaine idée
du journalisme
hors la vue de la haine orna hors la vue
du radotage avec l'intelligence mise au
service de l'analyse critique j'ai rien
d'autre à dire et bien parfait
commençons
[Musique]
rudy ricciotti grand prix national
d'architecturé vous avez inauguré cet
après midi avec le président de la
république et sa femme le 19ème le
gigantesque bâtiment que vous avez
réalisé pour la maison chanel porte
d'aubervilliers et vous publié chez nba
édition un nouveau livre coup de gueule
manifeste légionnaires vous venez en
effet de rejoindre la légion étrangère
dans la réserve citoyenne en tant
qu'officier supérieur colonel carrément
et vous écrivez dans ce livre que la
légion représente une avant-garde que
personne n'avait vu venir tout d'abord
il faut bien imaginer que ce sont des
étrangers qui très jeune s'engage autour
des 20 ans ils ont tous connu la
souffrance et l'humiliation
donc ce qui est déjà un patrimoine
incroyable et donc lorsqu'il s'engage
dans la légion ils le font ils le font
avec
un travail une noblesse qui me touche
beaucoup ils sont méconnus moi je
connais bien maintenant il exige des
officiers je les côtoie sont des gens de
très grande valeur au service de la
france je sais que ça fait très vulgaire
de parler de la france aujourd'hui le
moi j'aime mon pays comme immigré
italien d'une famille on en a perdu 6
quand même je vous le dis je me sens une
obligation de les aimer et je les aime
parce que vous savez on dit que les
légionnaires ne sont pas français par le
droit du sang ils sont français par le
sang versé et si on a quelques reproches
à leur faire
lorsqu'ils combattent c'est pas à eux
qu'il faut le faire si on chef des
armées le président de la république
voyez-vous sur n'est pas d'accord et
l'exercice de la discipline de la
rigueur de l'humidité permanente de la
solidarité de la fraternité les amène à
porter au plus haut
leur valeur c'est à dire la finalité
l'honneur et la fidélité
extrêmement rare aujourd'hui l'honneur
la finalité de crottin on peut le voir
comme ça mais c'est surtout l'idée que
vous développez dans ce manifeste est
qu'au fond la légion tient les promesses
de la république a mais évidemment la
légion mais pour moi le laboratoire le
dernier laboratoire qui participe de la
solidification du socle républicain par
un esprit de fraternité de discipline
des coûte vous savez le légionnaire
apprennent le français pour devenir
légionnaires 150 races cultures
religions langues différentes qui a
quatre mois après le français pour
devenir l'originaire c'est leur destin
il faut savoir ce que ça de quoi ça
parle évidemment donc très rapidement
j'ai compris que la région était le
réceptacle de l'héritage de
l'universalisme républicain et que c'est
une école et c'est une école à mon année
on assiste le dise location de de
l'édifice républicain
faut avoir un peu conscience de ce
travail j'avais à dire scolastique ont
pris un mois peu prétentieux que la
légion fait on ne demande pas aux
légionnaires 6 un avis sur la france ils
ont pour mission d'être solidaire de la
france de la défendre c'est d'ailleurs
assez extraordinaire quand on voit le ce
que c'est un club bien on pourrait dire
la légion c'est un ordre
très affectif un ordre religieux ou de
chevalerie mais en tout cas on ya croisé
aussi bien l'arche l'écrivain ernest
young heures le compositeur colporteurs
blaise cendrars qui était suisse on
croit qu'ils étaient français mais non
ils étaient suisses le peintre hans
hartung l'écrivain arthur koestler le
réalisateur william wellman grands
réalisateurs des ânes et mulets et du
début du parlant et dans la légion la
guerre et l'esprit justement de l'ordre
ou de corps dont vous parlez un bel
appart et s est engagé à 18 ans à bijoux
étrangères et bien la guerre de 14 ans
auprès de la france voilà françois
sureau plus récemment
écrivain qui est comme vous dans la
réserve et membre de l'académie
française
alors il ya la fraternité qui est très
importante dans la région parmi les
promesses que tient là que là que la
légion tient pour la république il ya la
fraternité parfois on est même entre
anciens ennemis
bien sûr c'est arrivé mais bien sûr est
arrivé notamment en 45 oui des soldats
d'armes ennemis qui ont déserté pour
rejoindre les rangs de la légion
étrangère les allemands 9 ans qui se
retrouvaient ensuite à diên biên phu
puis voilà évidemment ceux qui venaient
de les contenir l'étalement du passé
aussi à d'autres époques où justement on
garde tout on n'efface jamais rien le
fait qu'on efface votre passé quand vous
rentrez dans les légions c'est quelque
chose qui prend tout son sens
aujourd'hui c'est un acte purement
symbolique
puisque ça concerne le nom il faut dire
aussi que c'est pour permettre à ces
jeunes d'avoir une nouvelle chance dans
la vie ils ne sont pas marqués au fer
par le destin malheureux qui était le
leur
car même lorsqu'il arrive en france et
muni à jamais je peux vous dire que
l'interpol travaille beaucoup sur le
recrutement il n'ya que un candidat sur
lui qui a mis a nui légionnaires il n'y
a pas de crime de sang ce n'est pas vrai
et ce sont des gens qui sont mis qui
sont mis en devoir d' écoute
d'instruction mais en même temps
d'archaïsme de rusticité
d'autonomie ils sont un peu les gaulois
a finalement une certaine manière ils
ont un côté gaulois ne une sur la durée
cet acte de résistance mais vous savez
ce qui est extraordinaire pendant locaux
vides
toutes les frontières étaient bloqués il
y à des étrangers qui ont traversé le
pays malgré les frontières bloqué pour
venir frapper à la porte de la légion
qui a traversé le rhin à la nage il y en
a un autre qui est venue du népal sur le
toit d'un camion mangeant des pommes de
terre crue est arrivé à rentrer mais ces
gens là sont extraordinaires comment ne
pas être plein d'admiration pour ces
gens qui sont subjugués par la france
parce qu'elle représente j'en connais un
en particulier qui était dans un pays
slaves et puis comme il avait fait des
études d'art il est parti en allemagne
avec une bourse pour faire des études
d'art il était frais styliste très
sophistiquée sur des icônes et puis
c'est vraiment cachette s'est barré la
rejoindre les gens ses parents l'ont
cherché pendant un an ils ont retrouvé
il tarde et je lui dis mais pourquoi tu
as fait ça il me dit je m'ennuie dans
l'école d'art il n'y a pas un projet en
belgique il n'y avait pas de projet
esthétique il ya le fait d'être toujours
prêt ça aussi c'était c'est que ces
petits pics de la légion ils sont
toujours prêts effectivement bon moi je
ne suis que je le fis que les chômeurs
de papier ou d'opérettes dire la vérité
donc je suis pas je suis pas au plus
près des combattants même si je peux les
côtoyer toute l'admiration et
l'affection que je leur porte il y à
cette disponibilité
permanente qui est incroyable c'est une
fidélité aux devoirs républicains
quel que soit le jour de l'année ils
sont disponibles j'ai rencontré pendant
les fêtes de noël légionnaire un
capitaine sur le port de mon village il
était avec sa femme enceinte il avait un
landau qu'un bébé et une petite gamine
qui doit avoir 5 ans il me dit le 2
janvier je pars en opex son mari qu'elle
aime envoyer un mot et me dit mon
colonel votre votre lit m'accompagne
dans les pensées extra gilles répondre à
un hommage très appuyé en dix ans mais
je vous félicite pour votre courage pour
votre abnégation
pour votre solidité et tu sais ce qu'ils
me répondent par texto il me dit non
l'abnégation le courage c'est ma femme
le don de soi l'esprit de sacrifice
aussi c'est ce qui caractérise la légion
en tout cas les légionnaires à vos yeux
on va écouter je parler avec un je
connais un commandant qui lui a fait
nombre d'opex qui me dit monsieur
risotti vous savez ce qu'on part au
combat on n'a pas besoin dans la légion
ne sont retournés pour savoir si des
camarades
jamais on a vérifié ça on sait qu'ils
sont avec qui s'en faut lutter c'est
c'est assez fascinant d'ailleurs comme
cet uniforme et le képi blanc qui
l'accompagnent ont été de puissants
mythe cinématographique on regarde
depuis le début des années trente corps
brûlé avec gary cooper d'avoir un
certain nombre d' affiches monde le
grand jeu et ça va jusqu'à belmondo dans
les dents les morfalous et plus
récemment d'ailleurs deux films bon
travail et mon légionnaire tous les deux
sur les légions réalisés par des femmes
pour la première fois mais c'est vrai
que tous ces films depuis depuis presque
un siècle maintenant se servent de la
légion vous avez dû vous revoir un
certain nombre jean baptiste thoret
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui les
caractérise tous va je pense mais en
ressent avec ce que vient de dire rudy
ricciotti je pense qu'il ya cette idée
que les légionnaires s'est pas
complètement l'armée à dire que là on a
très souvent on essaye de réticences
enfin un peu réflexe à l'égard de
l'armée du corps constitués et c'est le
légionnaire il ya on a presque le
sentiment que c'est un peu le on
pourrait presque dire le rebelle de
l'armée comme vous disiez celui qui est
qui est malgré tout dont la personnalité
est quand vous en parlait d'ailleurs
vous parlait très peu de l'institution
vous parlez de jean famille mais sa
famille a les gens et moi je n'ai aucune
réticence d'abord avec la défense
nationale qui est quand même qu'ils sont
et qui sont absolument disponible devant
le pouvoir politique d'accord les jours
mais au défi d'avoir en officier vous
exprimer son point de vue politique mais
mme mouret sous alcool et après tous les
légionnaires je veux reprendre cette
phrase de pasolini ce qui parlait de la
police et carabiniers en italie pendant
mes impressions des années soixante dix
il dit juste à rappeler qu'ils sont les
fils du peuple si ça vous dérange pas
qu'ils soient eux les fils du peuple
voilà et presse à sacrifier pour
défendre l'héritage démocratique
d'ailleurs quelqu'un vous dit et vous le
décrivez dans votre manifeste rudy
ricciotti que le secret de la légion
c'est que les seuls vrais légionnaires
ceux qui font vivre la légende cette
légende qu'on voit dans tous ses films
la légende de ce sont les soldats les
soldats du rang et sous-off ah oui ça
c'est dan imagine je te dire que tous
les officiers supérieurs les saint
cyriens ont une humilité extraordinaire
troublante devant les soldats du rang
alors qu'ils sont tous déjà je pense
qu'ils portent sur une culpabilité
existentielle les officiers supérieurs
c'est qu'ils sont tous très érudit ils
ont tous fait qu'anne hypokhâgne ou
maxime aspects ils ont bien conscience
de ce privilège ce privilège il le
ramène à la distance qui convient
d'avoir pour éviter de se vautrer dans
la vulgarité la prétention dans la
légende il n'y a pas de prétention d'un
légion auxerre on est fidèle et on est
disponible en même temps ils
construisent à y construire et normé et
quand on les voit défiler le 14 juillet
avec l'heure h alors un jour j'aurai
toujours le 14 juillet depuis chez
enfants c'est parce que j'entends
l'animatrice de la télévision qui dit ah
le tablier est lâché par rappeler que
les combats sont difficiles je me dis
mais comment la télévision français peut
être aussi stupide c'est le symbole des
bâtisseurs et d'ailleurs si on fait
l'inventaire de tout ce que les jeunes
agents parlent dans le livre on
s'aperçoit qu'ils ont davantage
construit que détruit finalement ils ont
asséché des marais de la plaine de la
mekerra
a sidi bel abbès il y avait une
part d'égoïsme au maximum non ils ont
fait beaucoup d'action d'aménagement
même du talent de reprise hôpitaux
reconstruit des ouvrages d'intérêt
public mais mais tout ça est très
méconnue et je crois que c'est très
vulgaire de ne pas s'intéresser
à cette mythologie qui est en même temps
une réalité est quelque chose qui parle
beaucoup de tendresse il semble vous
savez les légionnaires sont très
attachants très très bas ils sont
d'autant plus attachant qu'il ya cette
mythologie ces bateaux graphique qui
n'est pas proprement française on a vu
avec les affiches pour garder c'est
beaucoup les américains qui ont été
fascinés par la légion et donc ils ont
quelque chose d'attachant au delà de nos
frontières ah ben écoute et ils ont une
réputation évidemment dans tous les pays
d'europe également
évidemment ils ont une réputation mise
en réputation pour l'heure pour leur
bravoure
leur leur capacité de combattre le nez
situation désespérée ce qui quand même
je vous déconnez les conventions
caractéristique française c'est quand
même s'ils ont subi de nous mêmes
écoutez les commandos les commandos
contre ou d'un certain bataillon que je
sois au 1er régiment étranger de
cavalerie qui sont des blindés sont des
gens extrêmement impressionnante par le
silence
cette personnalité du silence du silence
total de la réserve de la capacité d
écoute je ne viens je suis très bavard
lorsque je reçois des légionnaires chez
moi et je reçois autant des soldats du
rang que des officiers
gérante je parle trop ils attendent que
je parle parce qu'il sent aussi très
respectueux très admirateurs ici un
architecte ou un architecte et un
architecte côté d'un légionnaire mais
vous rigolez ou quoi tu veux passer une
soirée à t'emmerder tu n'as pas ça gaze
architectes toit et des cultures e rei
les légionnaires la tuerie imputée
résiste bien à mon tournoi de rome
vous dire ils sont solides il ya eu un
réseau de prostitution qui a été
démantelé en octobre dernier des
militaires ou anciens militaires de la
légion ont été arrêtés j'imagine que
vous avez de bruit c'est ali drôlerie
c'est à nîmes coûté non il s'agit pas de
défendre seulement nous constaté que que
des légionnaires qui sont enfermés
pendant cinq ans sans femme dans un
régiment dans une caserne entre l'âge de
25 ans qui sont bourrés de testostérone
et de masse musculaire qu'ils aient des
désirs sexuels faut pas trop s'en
étonner non plus donc qui pratique qui
consomment des prostituées c'est à peu
près inévitable dont ils n'ont pas trop
le temps de construire du lien social
puisqu'ils sont encasernés par contre je
suis plus enfin je pense que vous êtes
moins choqué par le fait que la
principale personnalité préférée des
français
un écologiste célèbre soit pris dans un
système de harcèlement sexuel répété que
d'autres politiques dans de la
pédophilie
marc est donc bon moi je suis pas choqué
que des légionnaires des désirs sexuels
qui s'adresse à des prostituées et vous
dites aussi que la légion au fond c'est
l'alliance du du g10 gaulois et de la
légion romaine ah bah oui d'ailleurs il
ya il ya énormément de similitudes entre
la légion romaine et la légion étrangère
notamment sur le fait que l'acquisition
de la nationalité c'était pareil d'un
romantique au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années de service de fiabilité le
combattant a été repérés comme étant un
bon soldat romain c'est pareil en france
sur l'apprentissage sur la notion de
répétition sur l'acquisition de la
langue sur la fidélité au commandement
sur le courage
sur la solidarité des autres un jour un
jour m'a passé je devais faire une
émission sur cette émission catholique
de dimanche matin qu' aujourd'hui jour
de ces tombes sur moi et en mode en un
texte de l'évangile de saint matthieu
dans le climat je lis le passage où un
légionnaire de rome j ai demandé au
christ de sauver la vie d'un de ses
hommes mais ça tombe juste sur moi c'est
incroyable
il me demandant comment taire alors moi
je dis coûté
qu'une crise ça veut la vie d'un homme
ça me paraît la moindre des choses
c'était censuré pour le christianisme
quand même à la vérité révélée il
occupait après c'est le trou des halles
alors à vos dogmes
s'était pas nos stx était à 9 gardes ont
gelé par contre qu'un légionnaire vient
de demander au christ de sauver la vie
de ces hommes lui incarne le message
chrétien
lui incarne toute cette mémoire cette
perspective historique du christianisme
ça aussi ça a été coupée
et commentaires jean-baptiste aurait en
vous écoutant parler je me disais mais
nous a effectivement cette popularité de
la figure du visionnaire mais dans dans
la presse que dans la pop culture dans
le cinéma etc je me dis qu'en fait de
façon presque inconsciente ils ont
peut-être deux ou trois traits qui sont
le l'antidote notre époque star que 1 il
n'y a pas de délit provenance quand on
est légionnaires tous conviennent c'est
ce que vous disiez que vous soyez
musulman exactement agnostique
absolument juif chrétien hisanori un fou
c'est vrai du tout le sujet le sujet ce
qui les réunit c'est l'appartenance à
une grande chaîne abc intéressant avec
un lien d'affection total et surtout de
solidarité au combat voilà des convives
dans une époque on est toujours à savoir
d'où vous venez pour éventuellement vous
ramenez votre ligne est ou ce que vous
avez fait à l'origine vous remettre le
passé dans la figure donc à cette idée
qui a pas de prénom il ya cette idée
qu'on est ce qu on fait ça que ça aussi
c'est intéressant c'est pas le titre ou
le diplôme qui qui vous donne la
légitimité c'est votre action lorsque
les américains aiment autant les
légionnaires parce que c'est très
américain ça tu es ce que tu fais en
france tu tu es ce que tu dis les pis si
par moments ce qu'on fait est pas
terrible ça n'entame pas la légitimité
pour moi mon avis un vrai problème et
l'autre chose c'est la question de
l'individualisme c'est que c'est des
gens qui pensent comme vous le dit une
pièce de leur d'abord à l'autre cette
espèce d'esprit de corps ça que la
présence de l'autre qui est toujours là
sans même qu'on ait à vérifier qui est
là je pense que dans notre époque
totalement narcissique ou on pense qu on
converse avec des sels gray est
absolument fascinant que je pense et
trois traits qui sont complètement
d'acronis à vesoul et désiré en même
temps dans les commandements du
légionnaire a dit comment
tu abandonnes ni tes frères d'armes il
était blessé ni tes armes tu dois être
toujours propres le tenue bien rasé ils
vont au combat en se rasant ya pas de
barbe comme ça vous rendez compte ce que
ça veut dire comme d'un hattrick sommes
deux siècles en arrière et
sur ce sujet
il ya un des commandements qui est
incroyable qui dit tu te bats sans haine
avait le respect endurance qui t'a pas
me dire ça coûterait la vie quotidienne
dans ce bassin m on est rendus dans la
haine permanent avec avoir le multimédia
ce que ça donne leveaux qui ce temps
dans lequel nous sommes c'est une boule
incandescente de haine qui déferle sur
la france non
ça s'intitule manifeste légionnaires ça
vient de paraître chez mg b e édition et
ben je vous propose qu'on regarde tout
de suite la bande-annonce du film de
jean baptiste thoret sur michael cimino
le réalisateur de voyage au bout de
l'enfer de l'année du dragon ou de la
porte du paradis et puis juste après on
fera une pause
facile non
[Musique]
gospel
j'arrête
[Musique]
moi
m nawa qui touchent au but un tifo ning
sur trois gardiens ministre la guinée
est chimérique et ps2
écoute
de brandebourg vaste avec il
[Musique]
et
bien connu michael cimino on entend
d'ailleurs beaucoup sa voix vous l'aviez
enregistré avant de faire ce film nous a
quittés malheureusement pourquoi
l'avez-vous intitulé un mirage américain
pourquoi un mirage américains parce que
je pense que le mirage c'est ce qui
définit à la fois ce qu'était michael
cimino en tant que êtres humains et
aussi donc tous ces films c'est que
c'est quoi le mirage c'est quelqu'un qui
est à la poursuite d'une image qui
existent ou peut-être n'existe pas et je
pense que ma queue de cheminots toute sa
vie mais pour l'avoir côtoyé puis
surtout pour avoir vu ces films parce
que moi je pense que dans les films les
individus sont là en fait qu'on va voir
ensuite les cinéastes très souvent à une
confirmation qui sont deux choses qu'on
voit déjà dans les films mais tout ça
vite cheminots à poursuivre une espèce
d'image qu'on pourrait appeler images
d'epinal on voit pas ce que dire de
l'amérique est ce que ça existe sept
americana et chimie l'eau était un grand
admirateur de john ford c'est quelqu'un
qui avait quand même une vision assez
haut de lui-même qui s'intéressait très
peu aussi las de sa génération par
contre il voulait se reconnecter avec un
grand héritage qui aurait été fort de
king vidor luchino visconti des gens
comme ça et il avait sans doute entre la
mélancolie à nostalgie cette idée que de
reprendre la mairie tel que ford à la
fin de sa carrière là et montre et être
là méritent des communautés incité cette
idée que les ja pas d'amérique s'il n'ya
pas de peuple américain c'est pas parce
que ça m'amuse par rapport à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure cette idée que
l'amérique c'est le peuple américain et
donc c'est des gens qui viennent qui
sont tous étrangers a parlé dernier
natif et qu'il va falloir intégrer mais
le problème c'est toujours pareil c'est
qu'une communauté si l'on ouvre trop
elle se dissout aucun cas y'a plus
d'amérique et si on la referme trop elle
s'étiole et asphyxient ses frontières
chinoises sont damnés film est cheminot
en fait a fait tout son cinéma des
voyages bout de l'enfer qu'elecam
l'histoire d'une petite communauté que
moi je suis allé filmer dans le noyau
dans le trou du cul de l'américain
subway qui s'appelle mingo junction
c'est une communauté qui un jour et est
touchée par une catastrophe qui
s'appelle la guerre du vietnam et sera
plus appeler n'importe quoi et qui va
tenter de se reconstruire et donc chi
minh hoa a poursuivi comme ça cette
espèce de mirage d'amérique dont oliver
stone
10 un moment dans le film il a beaucoup
hésité stone a participé au film me
disant mais j'ai pas la même vision que
vous qu'avec de michael cimino judy
m'écouter ya aucun problème au contraire
je vais pas faire un portrait
hagiographique à l'américaine ou d'un
tout et amazing si vous voulez et il me
disait mais moi j'ai le sentiment que
quand on voit les films de michael
cimino on aimerait tous que ça ressemble
à un film de john ford mais la réalité
c'est un film de sidney lumet tu es je
pense qu'on est vraiment dans cette
espèce d'entre d'eux parce que juste
pour pour finir c'est que
ce que je dis pourrait laisser penser
que tchimou est un nostalgique qui veut
restaurer une amérique qui a disparu non
c'est quelqu'un en fait qui veut retenir
au fait qu'ils avaient envie de se
demander si quelque part n'y avait pas
toujours un idéal américain a restauré à
sauvegarder ce qui l'empêchait pas
d'être extrêmement critique par moments
sur l'amérique dont la porte du paradis
qu'une décharge les plus violentes sur
le mythe du melting-pot américain on va
y revenir on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après pour pouvoir parler
d'eux michael cimino et de michael mann
aussi auquel vous consacrer un livre
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec rudy ricciotti
et jean baptiste thoret jean baptiste
thoret critique et historien du cinéma
vous êtes déjà l'auteur d'une douzaine
de livres et de deux films le troisième
michael cimino un mirage américain sort
en salles il est consacrée au
réalisateur de voyage au bout de l'enfer
de la porte du paradis de l'année du
dragon
quelqu'un que vous avez bien connu qui a
tourné sept films en 20 ans et qui a
passé les vingt années suivantes à rêver
à des films qu'il n'a jamais tourné
quand
je vous demandais tout à leur caisse que
pourquoi vous l'aviez intitulé michael
cimino amira hass américain j'avais
envie de vous dire de donner la citation
que vous faites de cheminots que je
trouve assez génial et il disait faire
du cinéma c'est inventer une nostalgie
pour un passé qui n'a jamais existé
ouais ben écoute oui en fait c'est là
c'est la suite du mirage non c'est à
dire que c'est à la fois la conscience
d'une certaine manière qu'il faut bien
un idéal faut aller vers qu'hubert une
image donc on a envie de voir dans la
hutte dragons qui est un film qui a fait
une formidable et qui auront mickey
rourke qui sera la polémique dans les
années 80 l'un des personnages dit à
mickey rourke tu poursuis quelque chose
qui n'existe pas et que c'est quoi ce
que poursuit me car au delà du dragon
c'est que c'est un voilà c'est un
américain c'est un faux lac comme il le
dit lui même qui vient et qui aimeraient
que toutes les communautés américaines
se met au diapason de l'amérique ça y
est c'est notre dernier plan de 2 sur la
piste des manques de john ford tu pas si
vous souvenez fils de 39 dans lequel on
a un indien rueront un colon une
servante noire tout séjourne à un moment
donné dressent les yeux vers le ciel et
on voit l'érection du drapeau américain
ça c'est le fantasme fordien et c'est le
fantasme chi minh aussi tous ces gens là
pouvait à la fois être de communautés
différentes c'est ça l'amérique
évidemment et en même temps à un certain
moment pouvait se mettre en accord
autour dame d'une même show d'une même
image qui est l'idéal américain serait
formidable mais le problème c'est que
mickey rourke il veut tellement cet
idéal américain que ça en devient
presque pathologique il ya une forme
d'absolutisme et il va voir au début la
communauté asiatique de new york en leur
disant écoutez moi américain alors qu'il
épaule acquis d'origine mois américain
ses 200 ans votre civilisation de 3 4 me
dont je m'en fou maintenant vous êtes
aux états unis c'est très intéressant
tant que cheminot a aussi on pourrait
presque dire pris en compte la dimension
presque on pourra lire pathologique de
cette espèce d'image ou d'amérique
contente de retrouver en réalité moi
quand j'ai fait le voyage avec lui en
2010 2011 c'était sous c'était lui qui
m'avait dit à l'époque je devais passer
du temps avec lui pour écrire il m'avait
dit écoutez on va pas s'asseoir dans une
pizza de beverly hills pendant une
semaine 1 il m'avait dit si vous voulez
on comprendre mes films on va prendre la
route de pailhères non on va prendre la
route et c'est lui qui a fixé le voyage
de la californie au le colorado où on
allait voir un vieux cow-boy qui pour
lui incarner une forme d'americana et
qui s'appelait alan keller qui avait été
de le doubleur de james caan et le
doubleur de john wayne notamment dans
son dollars pour racheter les forces 68
cet homme était une scène de molosses
incroyable il avait des studios de mon
plastique tellement il est tombé de
cheval souvent et c'était intéressant ce
que le moment où j'ai vu cet homme que
colossale sur de ben jonson si l'on
voulait énorme qui a enlacé de chimie
nos hommes de l'est plutôt aristo
cultivé est une d'architecturé d'art
j'ai compris en fait ce que ce qui était
de cheminot c'était à la fois une
impulsion vers l'est 1 la vieille europe
il fera un jeu aux siciliens grand
amateur de visconti et en même temps à
désir d'amérique mais d'amérique
fordienne quoi véritablement et je pense
que c'était vraiment sale on pourrait
presque dire le paradoxe de bach et de
cheminots là on voit la fiducie si bien
derrière voilà ça c'est longueur c'est
le versant vieille robe de chino
abatteurs de aussi bien de deux
évidemment de juliano de l'italie de la
culture européenne du guépard de
visconti l'un de ses films fétiches ou
de dostoïevski et toute la littérature
russe quoi mais alors cette citation de
de chino faire du sihh débat s'est
inventé une nostalgie pourra passer qui
n'a jamais existé sauf que ça correspond
bien aussi à votre film qui est un très
beau film à mes yeux mais si vous n'avez
pas inventé une nostalgie pour ce
cheminot qui n'existe pas de la même
manière et ça m'étonne pas que l'hiver
stone vous ai dit mais en fait qu'il
visitait un peu élevé ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas la même vision que vous
james toback qu'on entend aussi beaucoup
ou même tarantino on voit bien que font
ils
iso une forme d'admiration paul cheminot
mais n'ont pas forcément la nostalgie or
quand on voit le film moi qui n'ai
jamais tellement estimé cheminots par
exemple alors que je trouvais c'était
plutôt un réalisateur qui se surestime
est lui-même justement en fait en voyant
votre film je me suis dit faut
absolument que je revois tous les films
de chino que j'ai chez moi mais que je
ne regarde jamais weeds alors après on
peut discuter je sais que vous avez
travaillé quinze jours on se reverra
dans un an ou deux il avouait faire
votre grand coming out ou mea culpa ça
viendra j'ai pas de doute là dessus non
mais je pense que après on peut discuter
je pense que tu chies minots il incarne
à la fois on pourrait dire une certaine
idée aussi du cinéma une façon de faire
des films parce que la porte du paradis
pour prendre cet exemple là donc on va
accuser d'avoir mis par terre le nouvel
hollywood en réalité c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué il faut juste retracer la
porte du paradis le jour où il est le
scar et du meilleur réalisateur pour
voir l'enfer et du meilleur film et puis
il ya plein de ce qu'a eu sur le
lendemain par tourner ce film et ça va
être une ça va ruiner sa réputation il
est au sommet de sa va ruminer sa
réputation le tournage devrait durer
deux ans faire coûté 38 millions de
dollars c'est énorme à l'époque où il a
dîné ça va être un échec commercial
échec commercial et d'après l'histoire
officielle qui est comme toujours il
contient une part de vérité une part de
enfin d'approximations c'est que
l'histoire officielle nous dit que ces
mecs chi minh au l'homme qui a été au
sommet d'hollywood ans on dit ce sont 19
un but venu de nulle part à contre
courant à contretemps c'est quand même
l'homme dans 74 à chercher clint
eastwood pour tourner dans son premier
film que une journaliste américaine
vient de traiter de fasciste personnes
de sa génération dans le milieu contre
culturelles progressistes américains de
l'époque ne serait allé chercher le nazi
clint eastwood lui il y va donc c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours été dans
l'anachronisme et le contretemps on
pourrait dire et quand il fait voyage au
bout de l'enfer aujourd'hui ou classique
ultra célébrer dont je pense que c'est
un des plus grands films de l'histoire
avec un ces quarantenaires année avec un
mélange entre les une forme on pourrait
dire viscontienne somptueux d'une grande
forme et un côté au moving c'est ça qui
m'intéressait c'est que c'est pour les
gens je suis allé voir dans le royaume
je bout de l'enfer c'est pas un grand
film l'histoire du cinéma ils me disent
pas quelle grand raccord forcer leur
visconti donc c'est beaucoup plus fort
c'est à dire que c'est ça le pouvoir de
le cinéma vous apprendre c'est pas un
truc entre cinéphiles historiens cinéma
s'est passé pas grand chose si c'est que
ça un film par contre ces gens là
quarante ans plus tard bah je voudrais
en faire le tournage a été un moment
mythologiques et moi quand giro tour du
réactive une mythologie et quand il
parle de voyage au bout de l'enfer une
parlent d'eux mêmes l'un d'entre eux me
dit moi quand je voyage au bout de
l'enfer d'abord il se souvient à peine
du nom de michael cimino mais quand je
revois but d'en faire je pense à mon
copain qui est mort dans l'usiné
sidérurgique à côté c'est là la
puissance du cinéma et le côté presque
au movie et après effectivement il va
faire donc la porte du paradis qui va
causer l'histoire officielle nous dit
que ça cause h une nouvel hollywood et
c'est pas vrai beaucoup de films avant
n'ont pas fonctionné new york new york
de scorsese sorcerer de friedkin etc etc
moi je pense que ce qui va compliquer la
gare de michael cimino en réalité ce
n'est pas ce film là quatre ans après
avec la ville dragon il est reparti
comme en 40 puis l'amérique adore les
gens qui s'effondrent les phénix la
renaissance il renaît cheminots à ce
moment là des dragons c'est le sicilien
qui va être un échec on pourra dire
artistique et comme christiane leur
beurre voilà en 87 et je pense que si on
doit dater le début de la fin où le
moment où la signale que le cas doit
pour la plupart un père son mojo où on
pourrait presque dire uci minot commence
à faire du ccino et c'est dur très
mauvais signe quand un cinéaste commence
à faire des films qui ressemble à ses
propres films consciemment que le derby
et c'est là le début de la fin c'est
sans doute le sicilien mais là cette
nostalgie dont vous parlez elle est
aussi liée à un moment d'histoire du
cinéma c'est que aujourd'hui michael chi
minh au vu son son rapport un peu
perfectionniste son indépendance ces
milliers de figurants qu'on voit c'est
pas des gens qu'on a mis sur un fond
vert sur ordinateur me sens vraiment là
ils sont vraiment là t'as que ce moment
où l'auteur c'était une parenthèse
enchantée a été roi hollywood on se dit
aujourd'hui quand on voit le niveau
moyen du cinéma hollywoodien on a
forcément non pas une nostalgie mais
comme une forme de regret d'un type de
cinéastes qui ne qui ne pourra plus
avoir lieu il ya qu'à voir les succès ou
plutôt les échecs de ce soit y compris
de steven spielberg ouest a history a
été un échec ces filous guillermo del
toro le dernier michael mann ex à sont
des filles qui ont été écrasés par quoi
par un film moi même j'avais même pas
entendu parler avant de savoir qu'il
avait qui avait écrasé ces films là
c'est spider man 2 on vit dans un autre
monde donc évidemment que quand on se
retourne vers le passé et c'est le deux
parce que jusqu'au 18 19
ans pas de macaques ont enfin produits
manufacturés bon peu importe mais c'est
à dire que si aujourd'hui un cinéaste
comme spielberg
est à deux doigts d'avoir un échec
financier avec le rsa story on voit bien
qu'on est sur un mot un changement
paradigmatique quand le sage mais j'ai
appris en regardant votre film qu'il
avait fait des études d'architecturé
michael choo bidouille qui
s'identifiaient beaucoup à frank lloyd
wright et d'autre il voulait d'ailleurs
il voulait faire un remake du durable
avec gary cooper dans lequel gary cooper
joue et d'architectes très inspirée de
frank oui alors c'était vous avez de
cheminot il est est ce que vous dites il
n'a pas tourné entre moment entre son
dernier film the chaser en 95 et le
monde sa mort 2016 20 ans où il a eu à
passer victime où il a travaillé n'est
pas il s'est pas tourné les pouces à los
angeles il a travaillé la santé de
développer des films ça s'est jamais
fait même un film sur le tour de france
qui voulait faire il voulait adapter la
condition humaine de malraux ça a été
vraiment une de ses arlésiennes et c est
évidemment le rebelle qui est un de ces
films fondateurs pour lui film de king
vidor de 48 avec gary cooper dans le
rôle d'une sorte de france grand film de
droite il faut dire le film de trois
films de droite parce que si on plaque
les trucs le palais s'est pas à défaut
non c'est pas de faire tout ce que je
veux c'est la prime de de justesse et
d'exactitude c'est que c'est plutôt un
grand film libertariens et ce qui est
derrière le rebelle de king vidor c'est
à une grande que vous devez évidemment
sans doute conem qui a écrit la grève un
des romans les plus lus par les
américains est à peu près ignoré en
france et fontaine aide qui va donner le
rebelle et sont servis une vraie
théoricienne de du libertarienne a eu
droit non comme on dit bien sûr de
droite conservatrice considérant que la
liberté de l'individu prime au dessus de
tout et chi minh au dont on vient un peu
d'esquisser portrait s'identifier à ça
cette idée fuck le système tel que ce
que dit au bac à aucun moment la
question de la vie de l'eau de ce que
coûte un film ne l'intéressait ne compte
que le geste artistique ou ce que moi je
vais faire à la fin donc évidemment on
comprend que le rebelle et coulait dans
les veines de michael cimino ils veulent
a voulu faire pendant très très
longtemps à rebecq il a écrit évidemment
le scénario etc mais il avait l'idée de
le proposer eastwood et ils soudent a
refusé non pas parce qu'il n'aimait pas
le rôle de ce personnage mais parce
qu'il a eu peur à l'époque d'être
comparé à gary cooper et il voulait pas
rentrer sur le terrain de gary cooper
donc il a dit non mais le rebelle oui
c'est un c1 c'est un à la fois un film
rebelle puis bien sûr 90 écouteurs je me
dis quand même que
cette énergie du cinéma relève de la
capacité à transformer
rectifier le réel le réinventer et
devient finalement à la métamorphose de
nous de nos névroses
sociale commune collective mis en 2d
animé grand format le des couleurs au
masteriser superbe extra c'est la mise
en jouissant de la névrose de notre
monde et en ce sens c'est plus fort que
leurs premiers d'architectes parce que
nous on a pour objet yab cession de
transformer le réel ou non seulement
vous le transformer vous le déclare vous
le vous le manipuler le des
manipulateurs incroyable des sorciers de
cinéastes se mutile sorcières on va
écouter d'ailleurs à cinéaste c'est
quentin tarantino dans votre film
puisque ça faire le bon lien entre
michael cimino auquel vous consacrez
donc un film et michael mann auquel vous
consacrer un livre on écoute tarantino
dans le film de jean baptiste thoret
[Musique]
mais les saxo bank
alors perso à michael mann qui est citée
par par tarantino vous lui consacrez
donc un livre intitulé mirage du
contemporain chez flammarion encore une
histoire de mirage
non mais sans doute le titre de ce livre
sur michael mann et a été enfin c'est
quelque chose qui a été pour moi évident
mais il ya déjà 7 8 ans donc voilà il ya
une conjonction à hazard d'actu qui veut
qu effectivement mirage mais vous avez
bien compris fédérer que ce sont deux
mirage qui n'ont rien à voir non 1 cm
presque l'entité le michael mann il faut
le rappeler c'est le réalisateur du
solitaire de hits de révélations dali de
collatéral de public enemies c'est le
contraire de cheminots parce que lui il
trône quasiment depuis 30 ans 1 enfin il
trop de wi2wi enfin enfin la carde man
elle est particulière parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui commence le solitaire
qu'on voit derrière vous qui date de
1981 alors lui c'est un autre paradoxe
par rapport à ma queue de cheminots
alors il partage tous les deux à mon
avis une forme d'anachronisme au sens
strict du terme akka moi je suis très
sensible c'est que c'est des gens qui ne
sont jamais à priori de leur temps moi
j'aime beaucoup ça parce que il ya comme
le dit cheminots à la fin du film une
part de moi vingt ans d'avancé une part
de moi vingt ans de retard et cheminot
michael mann c'est aussi une forme
d'anachronisme d'accès des gens en fait
qu'ils arrivent à capter le contemporain
parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'illusion d'être
dans le présent à titre personnel je
pense que quelqu'un qui me dit j'habite
le présent je suis dangereux je me
comprends je pense qu'il est tout de
suite ringard et dépassé je pense qu'on
est toujours en retard ou en avance qu
on est rarement de son temps et je pense
que michael mann c'est vraiment ça ils
arrivent en 81 donc c'est quelqu'un qui
al'âge de friedkin scorsese coppola de
toute cette générales de cheminots il à
3,6 millions mais pendant que tous ses
amis ou ses compagnons on pourrait dire
du nouvel hollywood fonds défi mais
fabrique le dernier âge d'or du cinéma
américain lui il est ailleurs il est
d'abord à londres il fait de la
télévision il écrit des épisodes de
starsky et hutch et c'est donc on va
presque dire qui ronge son frein en
réalité et donc paf premier film de ce
cinéaste américain zack smith au moment
où on plie boutique bon c'est
intéressant parce que ça crée une et le
sait le faire avec avec james est un pur
film des années 70 ans est un pur film
d'action dit que on peut dresser la
queue de comète elles sont dix le sort
de le réalisme l'acteur et en même temps
on sent déjà que sur des années 80
esthétiquement est en train de poindre
notamment via la musique donc le
solitaire c'est un film d'hana chronique
comme si michael mann était arrivé trop
tard au cinéma et ce retard va devenir
quelque chose d'obscène dans tous ses
films et puis ensuite il va faire un
deuxième fille s'appelle la forteresse
noire qui sera un échec colossal et là
il rentre à la télévision parce que bon
bah ça marche pas trop pour l'instant
pour faire cette fameuse série comme
showrunner miami vice qui va laver
bonheur n'existe pas c'est en fait c'est
lui qui va faire deux flics à miami
c'est le titre de la série française
voilà on les voit et alors vous ne
faisiez vous avez grandi en regardant sa
1re diane chaîné je me souviens d'aller
au début des années 80 abattant à miami
a circulé sur collins avenue ou ocean
drive de loger dans les hôtels carlyle
les lits qui était formidable d'un point
de vue architectural c'était pas du tout
à la mode même la plage à yamina
la bourse qui avait personne c'était
désertique et je me suis un verre en
louer une voiture décapotable le
chevrolet rouge décapotable
j'ai mené mon fils qui doit avoir quatre
en cinq ans on roule de nuit dans miami
il était émerveillé tutoyer il voyez la
dimension cosmopolite de la ville mais
c'est surtout le panorama architectural
qui étaient très présents paraissait
évidemment c'est une découverte des
vertus est imaginaire incroyable de l'
architecture de miami le français dès qu
un district certains comme ça tu
cherches un curare déco sommes curieuse
gracieuse et surtout marquée de deux
régimes décoratifs extrêmes ce qui était
tout à fait le contraire de la puissance
de la terreur minimaliste américaine
déjà d'être très active le béton et le
verre dans le mille les minimales comme
obséquiosité vous voyez donc et là je
découvre cette vertu narrative intense
d'une architecture qui sourit
architecture qui tarde la main
l'architectural de la tendresse été avec
dieu et avec un récit partage et de
comprendre populaire deux flics à miami
ça va donner à sa tombe de canons
esthétiques des années 80 on les doit au
fond à michael mann michael mann c'est
quelqu'un qui a grosso modo il y aura
évidemment beaucoup de nuances à
apporter mais à fkih a fixé la route
esthétique dans les années 80 avec la
série miami vice le côté le coup les
peler tons pastels l'architecturé la
musique tous les tubes électro funk de
l'époque c'est un des premiers à se
servir de la musique à la télévision
comme ça dans des séries télévisées
c'est justement aussi car même
à manille
surtout que mal avec la même de choisir
il ne voulait pas de couleurs vives donc
c'était vraiment comment accorder le
costume d'un acteur avec tel ou tel
bâtiment ils pouvaient même par moment
faire repeint des bâtiments de la vie
pour ça s'accorde avec le costume et
vice versa donc on a vraiment un
perfectionniste assez fou dans les
années 80 il fait ensuite sixième sens
manhunter il a fixé la feuille de route
esthétique des années 80 véritablement
on pourrait dire d'ailleurs à l'origine
du projet miami vice c'est un ticket de
métro sur lequel est marqué mtv cops
donc ces prix public de mtv les flics
d'omtv et dans les années 90 il va fixer
encore un canons esthétiques somptueux
qui évite la date qui fait voilà aucun
critique américain parlait du 2001 du
polar d'ailleurs que ça fait à peu près
fait 25 ans maintenant qu'on voit des
polars les quatre cinquièmes des polars
sont des sweats parce qu'il a fixé la
feuille de route de ce que c'est qu'un
polar on pourrait dire mais comment il
allait comment expliquez-vous parce que
c'est quasiment le sou la grande
question vous posez tout le long de
votre livre comment expliquez vous qu'un
type donc de la génération de scorsese
de palma de friedkin et de tout et de
chino donc du nouvel hollywood comment
vous expliquez qu'il a si bien réussi
après la fin du nouvel hollywood au
moment où quasiment celle inverse et qui
prenait mais parce qu'en fait il arrive
dans un endroit parce qu'au début des
années 80 il arrive dans un autre monde
donc il ya deux façons ou bien je
n'arrive pas à me mettre dans ce monde
là qui est grosso modo le monde de l'art
de la réussite un peu en toc l'élection
de ronald reagan l'arrivée lundi du ahly
jane fonda fait l'aérobic aller plus à
saigon on est vraiment dans un moment
années 80 qui est l'antithèse absolue de
tout ce qu'elles auraient été des années
70 et michael bad lui varie avec le
bagage seventies cet effet devises ont
quittés et c est il donc il tombe d'une
certaine manière pour lui dans le dans
la forme idéale de ce que beth sa
critique du capitalisme contemporain il
est un laboratoire permanent et or comme
michael mann a fait quand même des des
études ça reste il a un fond marxiste
avec michael matadi mois les rapports
économiques je te raconterai le monde un
film comme collatéral est un très tape
titre était marxiste absolument géniale
de ce que c'est que la pathologie du
capitalisme contemporain tom cruise dans
le film une sorte de tueur à gages
indifférent à tout qui ne s'intéresse à
rien qui ne pense qu'à son métier ultra
compétent mais d'un vide existentiel
total et qui à la fin devient une sorte
de terminer thor c'est une sorte de
version radicale vous dit d'ailleurs que
tous les héros des films de michael mann
sont des professionnels prêts à tout
sacrifier pour leur travail ben parce
que c'est le parce que michael mann ça
s'inscrit à la fois dans l'histoire du
cim américain qui a toujours valorisé le
professionnel voilà un être bon dans ce
qu'on fait c'est être en accord avec le
monde donc être bon dans son travail
qu'on soit voleurs boxeur peu un tueur à
gages joueur et lui reprend cette figure
la du professionnel en disant ok c'est
quoi la maîtrise pour elle même en bout
de course et quoi l'horizon
existentielle de jeunes gens qui sont
des professionnels accomplis et c'est là
qu'on peut dire qu'il ya deux programmes
dans les personnages de mad il ya d'un
côté le programme professionnel un
parfait et le problème existentiel c'est
oui mais alors la famille l'horizon que
le sacré à quoi ça fait rêver et c est
je pense finalement qu' il a montré la
crise mais indépendamment de ses
personnages de ce que c'est que cette
espèce de culture du professionnalisme à
tous crins c'est très bien mais pour
quoi faire et c'est pour ça que le
mirage du contemporain dont quidam et
rage différent d'une chimie dos et ça
c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui à mon avis
c'est la grande puissance critique de
ses films c'est pour ça que je suis
toujours à des gens voulaient comprendre
le contemporain mais politiquement
historiquement aller voir les films de
michael bay dit carrément que ces films
documentaires notre époque il se
concentre sur les bascules bien sûr un
moment où on est passé d'un mot d'une
époque à l'autre bien sûr mais je pense
que c'est la oumma des très forts à mon
avis c'est qu'il n'a jamais oublié cette
décennie dame ans et son côté sans doute
américains que la critique de porte vous
disiez tout à l'heure populaire que si l
aidant à la lenteur d'une sorte de
cheval de troie populaire si vous faites
un film militant ou à thèze pour la pour
la secte des convertis qui va toucher
les 3000 personnes qui sont déjà
d'accord avec ce que vous alliez ça n'a
aucun impact par contre ceux servis dans
la machine hollywoodienne du blockbuster
du mainstream et puis glisser un peu de
marques usine un peu jackson un peu de
marques cela vous avez gagné et man a
compris que il ne fallait pas assez
compliqué pour un français parce qu'en
france on a souvent tendance à penser
que la forme est coupable cette
générosité dont vous parlez plus c'est
agréable plus dans mon envie d'y être
puisque chatoyant puce est suspecte man
a compris qu au contraire pour faire la
critique du capitalisme
il fallait aussi prendre en charge sa
part de séduction tac convoi miami vice
on a tous envie de conduire une ferrari
cheveux au vent anna à miami ok ça c'est
la partie séduction dimensions
publicitaire du capital de contemporains
qui donne envie de tout consommer 1 et
puis derrière il va montrer l'envers le
début mai me lie c'est génial ça a l'air
super c'est à cette boîte de nuit ces
corps disponible cette musique ces
belles voitures tout est lisse l'homo
festivus de philippe murray quoi et puis
séquence suivante on rendre la réalité
qu'est ce qui a rendu possible la
surface et la prostituée ben c'est un
espèce de déchets numéro trois les
malades fall a dégagé et ses 7,7 ce
double axe qui rend la critique à mon
avis de man absolument passionnant set
prendra à la fois en charge la séduction
du monde contemporain du capital y de la
consommation est elle est réelle pour
tout le monde même qu'on déteste ça et
aussi une certaine manière produire la
critique mais l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre en réalité pourquoi il ne fait
plus de films avec l'habit fait plus de
films pour pour plein de raisons la
première c'est que son dernier film
black hat en 2015 a été a coûté 180 200
millions de dollars a été un échec
commercial colossal des états unis et en
france aussi puisque universal en france
à un peu saccagé la sortie du fis a
annoncé qu'il allait faire les fuites de
hits enfin c'est pas la suite il vient
il est en train de terminer le roman de
la prequel de it's très précisément vous
savez à hollywood vous valez ce que
votre dernier film il ya qu'en france on
peut faire comme ça des films pendant 15
20 ans s'en sont jamais avares de
spectateurs un an aux états unis ce
n'est pas le cas on a beau s'appeler
michael mann le dernier ne vaut rien
donc très très dur pour lui et puis on
voit bien que l'écosystème du cinéma
hollywoodien ou men stream aujourd'hui
est pas favorable pour un pour un
cinéaste auteur un peu exigeant etc
voilà à l'heure de ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui en salles c'est un peu
compliqué pour lui il a 78 ans il a déjà
une oeuvre à mon avis considérable elle
est quasi fait et je pense que s'il fait
encore un film dans le le panorama
actuel ça sera déjà formidable c'est fou
comme il a inspiré les autres
réalisateur michael mann très souvent
les cinéastes parle de mam un peu comme
autrefois dans les années 60 on parlait
de resnais ou avez vous alors ou même
comparé kubrick s'accélérer et norman
est un grand admirateur de stanley
kubrick et ont pesé on peut très bien
comprendre ta qu'une et on a le
sentiment qu'on voit un film de matt
d'un seul coup qu'on est passé à une
hauteur 1 la plupart des autres sont
dans le brouillard près de près de
l'aéroport michael matinée au dessus
mais esthétiquement il ya une puissance
il a une intelligence et je pense qu'il
a fait t'as que tout le monde se sert de
michael mann parce qu'il a en plus créé
des images iconiques vous savez c'est ce
plan devenu extrêmement célèbre de
robert de niro dans les hits rentrant
chez lui dans cette espèce d'endroit
pour le coup ce modèle du verre rien du
tout face à l'océan pacifique il pose
son flingue il va vers la vitre ils
regardent l'horizon c'est à dire qu'il
regarde son propre vide existentiel
voilà et professionnel mais à la fin
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est devenu une
image emblématique du cinéma de michael
mann qui a été reprise mais aussi bien
dans des films que dans des vidéos clips
français l'affluence esthétique de man
s'est notamment hissé un film qui a
intégré la pop culture on pourra dire
aujourd'hui merci tous les deux d'avoir
participé elle cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]